impeachment is the word of the day the
first step of the impeachment process of
Donald Trump has started and Donald
Trump is flying off the rails as a
result we will talk about all of this
this is an impeachment inquiry important
word a lot of people very clearly not
understanding the full process and why
would you impeachment of presidents is
not a common thing this was announced
yesterday by the Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi let's take a look the
actions of the trump presidency revealed
dishonorable fact of the president's
betrayal of his oath of office betrayal
of our national security and betrayal of
the integrity of our elections therefore
today I'm announcing the House of
Representatives moving forward with an
official impeachment inquiry I'm
directing our six committees to proceed
with their investigations under that
umbrella so there's confusion about what
this is and what this is not impeachment
is a long process there are three
primary steps and these can be
subdivided into even really ten or
twelve different steps but the
generality the three primary phases are
an impeachment inquiry if the inquiry
leads the Enquirer's to decide that
actually impeaching the president via a
trial is appropriate you go to an
impeachment trial by the House of
Representatives and after that phase is
complete phase two you go to Phase three
which is a vote in the Senate as to
whether or not to convict the president
and thus remove them from office now
this is not going to lead to a
conviction of Donald Trump in the Senate
and thus the removal of Donald Trump the
Senate is controlled by Republicans we
don't have to go through the details but
as you know if you've been following
politics for the last couple of years
with some very limited exceptions
Republicans are not interested willing
or even remotely considering removing
this president from office so the
process that Democrats will now follow
must be strategic and it must be thought
out because Donald Trump will try and he
is already trying you will see his
tweets moment air
to turn this around into he's the victim
he's a martyr just doing great things
for the United States and these
witch-hunt Democrats won't let him just
make America great again so this the the
goal here is hurt Trump in 2020 because
the impeachment process is not going to
remove Donald Trump so that then becomes
a question of are we confident that
Democrats can carry this out in the
right way is there going to be
infighting among Democrats around this
such that it will become a distraction
we already saw there's this a member of
Congress from Hawaii who is running for
president named Tulsi Gabbard she says
she's against what Nancy Pelosi is doing
are we going to see conflict within the
Democratic Party that will allow Donald
Trump to take advantage of this in some
way last night on I did a live stream on
YouTube about the breaking impeachment
news and there were a lot of people who
were saying David you know this talk of
impeachment backfiring that's a
Republican talking point no no no I'm
not talking about the process backfiring
insofar as the impeachment inquiry is
not warranted on the substance Donald
Trump clearly deserves at minimum an
impeachment inquiry will not put the
cart before the horse depending on what
the inquiry finds we can talk about
whether the impeachment trial is the
next step that's not what I mean when I
say backfire what I mean by backfire is
that if Democrats bungled the process if
Democrats bungled the PR around this it
will allow Donald Trump to paint himself
successfully as the victim martyr and it
will not hurt him in 2020 I've been
getting emails from people saying David
it's over for Trump Trump needs to
resign and set up Mike Peng Mike Pence
to pardon him the way that Richard Nixon
did number one it's unlikely that Donald
Trump's ego would allow that to happen
but I don't think it's necessary Donald
Trump is not going to be convicted on
impeachment by a republican-controlled
Senate before January of 2021 which is
when the next Congress and president
would be sworn in so there are two ways
that this can go given that Trump won't
be removed before the election number
this doesn't work because Americans get
exhausted by 14 months of it leader
however many months I guess 13 months
leading up to the election and it ends
up helping Donald Trump that's one way
the other way it can go is that the
inquiry reveals the president's
wrongdoing in such an uncontestable way
to such a degree that it destroys Trump
and Republicans in the 2020 election
when we go back to Bill Clinton people
like to remind me that Bill Clinton's
approval went up during impeachment but
remember number one Bill Clinton didn't
try to interfere
number two Bill Clinton had a strong
economy and number three what was at
issue were lies about an affair Donald
Trump has engaged in borderline
traitorous behavior and of course Donald
Trump is absolutely losing it on Twitter
which is an indication that he is not
going to allow this process to play out
calmly in the way that Bill Clinton did
I've been telling you for years
if impeachment starts what we've seen on
Twitter so far by Donald Trump will be
nothing compared to what we will see and
it's already happening Donald Trump
starting to wind up yesterday tweeting
such an important day at the United
Nations so much work and so much success
and the Democrats purposely had to ruin
and demean it with more breaking news
witch-hunt garbage so bad for our
country later tweeting presidential
harassment in all caps and then this
morning scaling it up even more Donald
Trump tweeting quote there has been no
president in the history of our capital
C country who has been treated so badly
as I have the Democrats are frozen with
hatred and fear they get nothing done
this should never be allowed to happen
to another president witch-hunt
so remember Trump won't be removed by
this impeachment because once again
Republicans control the Senate but
Donald Trump is already losing it if
there were to be I mean listen imagine
if Donald Trump were to be convicted and
removed by the Senate imagine the level
of violence that we would see happening
from trumpets I I would actually
consider staying away from public places
I really would but in the end that's not
going to happen and the conversation has
been a
about is the president going to be
removed and what is the strategy on that
basis the real question is should the
president be impeached given what we
know and the answer is as far as an
impeachment inquiry obviously yes
so this inquiry is the first step and it
is the correct step there is no question
about it the political strategy around
it is important given that the Senate is
not going to vote to convict but on the
facts obviously there is a completely
there's a completely obvious case for
why this impeachment inquiry is now
starting and it's not only Donald Trump
who's flipping out it's also really
Giuliani let's talk about that next